darkness rises at night to meet this is
not going to go
where you think
[Music]
hey everybody so there's been a whole
bunch of stuff going on around Star Wars
the last Jedi they're doing press state
right now so I will include some of that
in the video but there were a couple
really important quotes from the actors
talking about Snoke and what's going on
with Rey's character particularly Daisy
Ridley because she said she would be
leaving the Star Wars franchise after
episode 9 so we'll break it down but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be so much Star Wars stuff
coming really soon
there's even probably going to be a
trailer or a teaser for the Han Solo
movies sometime in the next couple of
weeks that's what people are expecting
just because that movies coming next
year and they haven't released any of
the footage yet but the actor Andy
Serkis who plays Snoke was doing press
just like all the other actors were and
there was this foreign magazine that
asked him if he's more powerful than
Vader in the Emperor and without
breaking a sweat he said Oh without
question he has limitless resources
let's put it that way just trying to not
be spoilery about it but also giving you
a whole lot of information about where
his character is coming from then he
followed up with a very Yoda type
clarification so Yoda very small
creature but one of the most powerful
people in the Star Wars universe so this
is how he describes snoke's appearance
and how that syncs up with his power
level he says there's a frailty and a
damage to snow his face is cleaved in
scars across his mouth contorted body
but without giving too much away he is
strong he is the dark end of the force
he's the leader of the first order and
he has his own agenda
he's a cruel manipulator we've talked a
little bit about snoke's backstory in
the theory that he comes from the outer
rim and even outside the galaxy
potentially there's some clues that
point us towards the outer edges of the
galaxy just the fact that he's not from
a place that we've ever been to in the
Star Wars universe before but also that
that origin of his is quite tragic like
very clearly something significant
happened to him to weaken him but also
gave him the power that he wields so
digging into this then we'll talk about
Rey leaving the franchise because that
says a couple big things about her
character too because of the fact that
the Saga films follow the Skywalker line
but digging back into Stokes power so
there's that seem that you see in
trailerware he's laying into ray and he
has that voice over where it says
fulfill your destiny in the way they cut
that is a little deceptive but it looks
like what's happening is is that he's
trying to trigger a response and her the
same way that the emperor tried to
trigger a response in Luke like the
Emperor really wanted Luke to fight
Vader so that it would unlock the dark
side in him he would give in to that
hate me
fulfill your destiny
so it sounds like something similar is
happening with Rey and kylo Ren in this
throne room scene here but it all just
goes back to the idea of him being this
clever manipulator in a way that the
emperor was not the Emperor was really
good at manipulating people but I think
the idea of escalation is really
important with this new trilogy like
they want to make it seem like it's
special so they make the Starkiller base
it's vastly bigger than the original
Death Star was you have Snoke who's much
more powerful than the Emperor was we'll
have to wait a little bit till we
actually see the movie and we can judge
whether or not he's more clever with his
manipulations than the Emperor was you
don't really get that from the footage
you've seen so far you only see him
using kylo Ren to get to Rey and it
sounds like he was interested in kylo
Ren for a time but he sense Rey is this
blank slate who was much more open to
manipulation than kylo Ren was because
she hasn't had any of the training that
kylo Ren had and doesn't have any of the
pedigree
so with kylo Ren he's sort of playing on
the idea that he's the dissatisfied
youth and trying to give him a purpose
but Ray doesn't have any of the baggage
that kylo Ren has because he still feels
the pull of the light like there's the
idea in the trailer that they're
implying he's going to try to kill his
mother Princess Leia but won't be able
to do it in Snoke we'll be really pissed
off with him via the really important
dialogue during all the trailers we've
seen is when Snoke is talking about raw
untapped power inside of her so she's
sort of like this well that sits on the
precipice of dark and light and he's
just hoping to get to her before she
gets more training which is why Luke is
like this isn't gonna go the way you
think it's going to go and it sounds
like Rey is going to either be captured
by Snoke because she's searching for
answers or it's like Return of the Jedi
and she seeks him out the way that Luke
sought out Vader in the emperor the
other funny thing about snoke's
character or the cool thing depending on
how you look at it is the way he loves
opulence like he wears those gold
flowing robes his throne room looks much
more opulent than Palpatine's throne
room he seems like wherever he did come
from he came from a position of wealth
and he's just obsessed with the
trappings of wealth and the power that
it brings along with the literal
that he wields through the force but
speaking of snoke's backstory the Outer
Rim territories they started to talk
more about Rian Johnson's new trilogy in
the idea that he's just going to take a
look at places that we've never been
before and characters that we've never
seen before they've started to open the
door on non Jedi force users a lot more
with these new films so we'll continue
to see that in his new trilogy and it
sounds like that's the type of place
that Snoke is coming from like he wasn't
a Jedi he wasn't a Sith
he was alive during the events of the
original trilogy but like I said he
comes from a really distant place the
Outer Rim territories the Unknown
Regions so it sounds like he had an idea
for what the Emperor was doing and was
just waiting for his moment because he
would have been a young man while the
Emperor was rising to power so early
theory is is that during last Jedi we'll
get a teaser for some of his backstory
they won't completely explain where he
came from and what he was doing during
the events of the original trilogy but
the new trilogy that Brian Johnson is
working on will cover a lot more of the
stuff that they teased from that in
these new films so I'm not saying it's
gonna be a Snoke origin trilogy though
just covered characters and things teas
related to Snoke in the places that he
came from the regions that we've never
been to before
like there's this crazy powerful new guy
that came from a region of space that
we've never seen before what else is in
this region stuff like that but I don't
think that we're gonna see any of those
films until after episode 9 so it's
gonna be a while they're gonna be
working on the story and the framework
for that for quite a while but the other
big thing everyone's been freaking out
about the last couple of days is that
Daisy Ridley confirm that episode 9 is
going to be the last Star Wars film that
she's in because a while ago the belief
was is that the next saga trilogy
10-11-12
would just cover the continuing
Adventures of rey finn in poe but now
that seems like it's not going to be the
case they haven't said anything about
them not doing more skywalker Saga films
after this saga there will always be
saga films there always be these other
films like Rian Johnson's trilogy which
is sort of intended to fill the spaces
between the saga films but the whole
idea that she would still be a
relatively young person you know sail
Luke Skywalker age as of episode six
when episode nine happens that she might
not even be related to the Skywalker
line which I'd totally be fine with
there been so many theories about who
her parents are and they did say that
they would give you some ideas for that
during last Jedi without just outright
saying these people are her parents like
they're not gonna be very discreet about
it but if you're like a really big
theory crafter they probably give you
all the clues that you need so we'll do
all kinds of videos about that but my
favorite one right now and this sort of
syncs up with the idea that she can
leave the franchise without just
completely destroying the idea that
they'll follow the Skywalker line is
that she's actually descended from the
wills themselves and that's why Snoke
wants her and why she's so powerful
because however you feel about the
prequels there's the idea that Vader
Anakin Skywalker was created through
Immaculate Conception
they literally caused his birth because
they have a will and they wanted to
balance the force that is some heavy
mythology that these new films have not
dealt with yet and I think that's mostly
because they want to ramp up to
crazytown like they want to get people
use of the idea of this new Star Wars
universe what it looks like who the
actors are before they just like throw
all the mythology at everybody but let
me know in the comments what do you
think happens to Rey at the end of
episode 9 if she leaves the franchise
leave all your requests for Star Wars
bonus videos in the comments below there
is a new round of that IMAX take a
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a Star
Wars related comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video t-dog please private
message be on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for that last big trailer
in the behind-the-scenes of them
practicing their lightsaber fights and
you can click here for brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight